economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniel hablando daniela muy
buenas noches en que base trámite la
reforma fiscal que originó las protestas
que hemos evidenciado en la jornada de
hoy en colombia hola santiago buenas
noches digamos inicialmente que el
gobierno de iván duque lo ha llamado el
ley de solidaridad sostenible pero en
realidad es su tercera reforma
tributaria en menos de tres años de
mandato el polémico proyecto fue
presentado oficialmente el martes en las
comisiones conjuntas económicas
la iniciativa tiene mensajes de urgencia
eso quiere decir que elimina algunos
pasos en su trámite y hace posible que
se apruebe antes de que acabe la
legislatura el próximo 20 de junio
después de comisiones va a plenarias en
las dos cámaras y luego a sanción
presidencial entre los elementos más
polémicos del documento de 110 páginas
santiago está la eventual imposición de
iva a servicios públicos de estratos
altos aunque funcionarios del ministerio
de hacienda ya han dejado entrever que
están dispuestos a ceder en este punto y
en otros también amplía la base grabable
es decir que él
mínimo requerido de ingresos para
declarar de renta va a ser más bajo que
ahora el gobierno defiende que el
proyecto crea una renta básica para
familias pobres y que va a recaudar unos
6.800 millones de dólares hablemos ahora
del salario mínimo en argentina que va a
aumentar de forma progresiva hasta el
mes de febrero así es el gobierno los
empresarios y las centrales sindicales
llegaron a un acuerdo para efectuar este
aumento en siete tramo santiago de esta
manera el salario mínimo que hoy está en
21.600 pesos argentinos o unos 230
dólares mensuales subirá progresivamente
en un 35 por ciento hasta 29 mil 160
pesos que equivalen como a 300 dólares
inicia con un alza del 9 por ciento en
abril y en adelante aumentos periódicos
de entre el 3 y el 5 por ciento hasta
completar el 35 en febrero de 2022 como
vemos en el gráfico el más reciente
aumento del salario en argentina fue en
octubre cuando estaba en poco más de 16
mil pesos y se decidió incrementarlo en
28%
estamos hasta marzo pasado hablemos
ahora daniela de esa disputa
internacional que hay entre el estado
peruano y la petrolera argentina
pluspetrol bueno les cuento que esta
empresa argentina quiere liquidar a su
filial pluspetrol norte que manejó hasta
el lote 192 este es el yacimiento
petrolero más grande de perú también el
lote 8 hasta finales de 2020 a pesar de
que tienen contrato hasta 2024 ambos
están ubicados en la prolífera amazonía
peruana perúpetro que es la agencia
promotora del sector del gobierno
peruano denunció que lo que quiere plus
petrol es deshacerse de sus obligaciones
haciendo que el país deje de recibir
unos 42 millones de dólares por la
terminación de su contrato y pidió a la
justicia local que impida esa
liquidación la empresa se defiende
diciendo que se ve obligada a cerrar
porque le han impuesto multas de casi 5
millones de dólares y sólo está
dispuesta a limpiar las zonas afectadas
durante el tiempo que ha estado allí y
no por daños ocasionados antes como le
está pidiendo el gobierno
río santiago llegó hasta un tribunal de
arbitramento en parís pasamos ahora a
hablar de las firmas tecnológicas que
han tenido una semana de récords en sus
resultados trimestrales
santiago pues las ganadoras de la
pandemia sin duda alguna son las
llamadas big tex o las grandes
tecnológicas que siguen mostrando
resultados récord esta vez en el primer
trimestre de 2021 miremos comparando con
el primer trimestre de 2020 a paul más
que duplicó su utilidad hasta 24.000
millones de dólares alphabet la matriz
de google le faltaron pocos dólares para
triplicar esa utilidad y facebook
también anotó el doble de beneficios
frente a un año atrás con casi 10 mil
millones también está microsoft que ganó
15 mil millones en los primeros tres
meses de las pocas que antonio ganancias
hablemos ahora de los indicadores
termina una nueva reunión mensual de la
reserva federal sin grandes sorpresas y
esto hizo que la bolsa de nueva york
cerrará en rojo las bolsas europeas se
cerraron planas luego de que el
parlamento ratificará el acuerdo
comercial post precise y en américa
latina'
el chileno castigó fuertemente la
sanción presidencial del tercer retiro
anticipado de pensiones y radicaron un
cuarto retiro santiago hablemos ahora de
la cifra del día para el cierre 18
millones de dólares un retrato pintado
por pablo picasso de françois y lo que
fue su musa y pareja durante una década
saldrá en mayo a subasta en nueva york
en una venta organizada por sobre peace
muchas gracias daniela es todo por el
momento quién france24 siga con nuestra
programación buenas noches
[Música]